[Music]
on this episode we talk about closing
the sale your drive getting in the way
of relationships and something insane
happens in the middle of the street
[Music]
this is
Gary B once I can step back let's try it
off the move but you can't get more of
it what's that lower
what number is this one point
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 1 42 of the ask gary vee
show a little gloomy here in the city
but my heart is not gloomy as I've just
landed from Indianapolis on a tremendous
weekend went to an amazing wedding flew
into India I'm connecting flights
grinded got there and then the payoff
came through as the New York Jets
stunned the Indianapolis Colts you know
Andrew Luck was 14 and 1 coming off of
losses pretty excited I'm in a good mood
that 10 and 6 prediction that you all
made fun of is starting to look a little
bit better I think this team is better
than people think I'm excited I know a
ton of you are Eagle fans looking
forward to smashing your faces and this
weekend though the official prediction
comes later in a week and we'll see what
that's all about so live in New York and
some other exciting news India is
finally back after being away for six
and a half months that was a long trip
it's a really long trip it's got a
pretty rad t-shirt on are these now
available for sale I know we put like
four thousand dollars to have this come
or is it up by then like now it's up all
right so Stefan links that up link it in
Facebook and YouTube and also play this
little clip that happened yesterday
after the Jets game
[Applause]
all right India for a little rusty doing
this let's get into the show
Jordan asks I've been hustling since the
age of fourteen I now work 12 maybe 15
hours a day I love what I do but
sometimes I fear my Drive works against
me particularly when it comes to getting
in the way of relationships with friends
how do you deal with that I can't switch
off yeah I mean this is something I
struggle with this well I mean when
you're on 24/7 365 it's difficult to
shut down it's difficult to change from
you know in the zone to in the zone and
it works in Reverse for and I'm sure
right like right now it's hard for me to
reach trigger back into the work zone
off the high of the sports brain that I
was rolling with over the weekend look I
think that I think that actions speak
louder than words and if these
relationships matter to you you're gonna
figure out how to hack and figure it out
it's as simple as that there's just
nothing else to say hello and so you
know you've got to put in the work
you've got to learn how to shut down I
mean sometimes it takes an hour two
hours three hours four hours maybe some
sort of routine you know working out has
been a good transition period for me you
know that's worked for me in the past or
in the recent times something that lets
you transition or what I tend to do hey
little man no no worries I think that
another thing that I did that was kind
of strategic was I raided and ranked my
relationships and then when I was
segwaying into off of work mode into a
weekend or the holidays I would um I
would actually scheduled meetings
according to what I thought of them so
like my mom would be later than may be a
solid friend because then I feel like I
was in the rhythm of that zone so I
think you've got a hack and make it work
for you but your actions are louder than
your words meaning you can't have the
excuse of my brain is always on it means
that you've chosen your business your
entrepreneurship and your ambition over
those relationships which by the way and
this is not super popular I find out to
be okay I don't think it's Noble I don't
think it's nice it's just a reality and
there's
a lot of people that do it you know
especially as you look higher and higher
up the pyramid you look at the Oprah's
and the Michael Jordan's and you know
this is these are the choices that
people make and so I think you've got to
make yours and I think that you need to
live your life and not take the judgment
of all these people however you know
just accomplishing your goals the
money's the sports teams that whatever
they are to have that by yourself and
not to share that with the people you
love the most I think is a fairly lonely
place I needed to keep that keep that
into serious consideration
so he'll asks why did you stop forcing
people to ask questions from Instagram
this is a great question so he'll
actually pick this out and send it to
the team because I felt that I finally
had picked up my rhythm and momentum on
Instagram if you look back at the point
when I was really pushing that narrative
as a function of this show I was
hovering in the thirty forty fifty
thousand follower range not the
following matters but don't forget on
Instagram matters a little bit more
because I feel the attention graph is
there and everybody seeing everything so
I'd rather have a hundred thousand there
than maybe a million person email list
or a million Twitter followers so I was
believing in Instagram I knew I needed
to build it up and really I created a
function on this show to create more
awareness more behavior more interaction
between me and you and Instagram and you
and your friends on Instagram finding
out about me on Instagram so it was very
tactical very strategic I stopped asking
because I feel as though I've gotten to
a place where I've got a better cadence
of momentum there's ads now I don't want
to create unlimited friction with you
and New York and myself so like I want
you to be able to ask questions the way
you want to ask them so it was a
strategy in a moment of time for three
to four months I executed what I needed
out of it
and I move on to the next strategy and
the reason I picked this question is I
want to make it very evergreen to
everybody and make them understand that
strategies have life cycles what worked
for you three four years ago or three
four months ago or three four days ago
can be debated and switched and I I
think way too many people find something
that works for them and they milk it
until there's nothing left in the cow
Charles asks what service do you use to
make these amazing images Charles that's
a very very good question this one's
super easy this uh speaks to something I
believe which is scaling the unscalable
every time people ask me about image
quotes this one and this one you have
some work today Stefan and this one
people always tween they're like what
happed to use what do you do nope just
use the great Andrew and Zack design
team mainly Andrew now who also design
this amazing t-shirt buy it now and so
you know really what I'm doing there is
just scaling the unscalable you know
there is no app everybody thinks
everything's got to be so scalable
notices on my hand I have a design
person obviously look and it's
interesting I have the bated turning it
into an app and opening it up to
everybody but for now it's just done by
hand there's a lot of texting I'll
actually put my phone yeah there's a lot
of texting that goes on between me and
Andrew where I just get a thought and
you know get ready do you rock I don't
know are you gonna want to have my uh
are you gonna want to have my phone no
I'm not gonna give it to you so because
you're not going to be there so you
can't do it like you'd like to normally
at it but let's just find Andrew
see it yeah so there you go you could
have been a bus with an image of me from
the Monday morning video in the
background and a smaller font saying
watch the video now I mean yeah then you
know that happens good old-fashioned
thoughts at execution keep it simple
let's go what wasn't going that Felix
I'm feeling I was about to go into some
sort of like da huh
Igor asks when is it okay to lie in
business that's it to sing the 14 year
old version of me would have said any
time all the time go for it you know I
think the answer is never
I I don't see any value prop I think
that having self-confidence and
believing that you could do something
you've never done before is a great
thing for business but I think you got
to lay those cards out to the person
that's making that decision you can't
say we've executed a campaign like this
before sorry you can't say I've done
this before I've sold this before what
you can say is I truly believe I can do
it because of these things but uh faking
the funk has diminishing returns puts
you in a curious spot and uh and when
you define it as lying versus a slight
little embellishment or a little bit of
hyperbole when you when you go to lying
I think that has no place in the
business world or in life and then take
it from somebody who grew up a liar it
was very tough for me as a kid to break
that habit this is one of the
disproportional reasons I value my my
dad's fatherly advice he really snapped
me out of it took me a long time I can
we believe it's the reason that most
people struggle with uh with consuming
me at first and don't know how to take
me because I do think there's a lot of
[ __ ] DNA that I started with but I
chipped away chipped away and and that's
a scoop no-go place
video editors yeah yeah I gotta have
those
we're really hacking this show together
so been very
yeah what's your name Adam that was
pretty amazing thank you for doing that
that was stunning thanks brother holy
[ __ ] that was awesome that was
unbelievable uh they just went this one
of the great humblebrag
lucky moments of all time all right that
was insane all right here we go
hey Gary what's going on Shawn Mitchell
here I've got a sales question for you
in the last couple of weeks I've lost
two really big deals that I was
anticipating closing on the first call I
felt like I did a really solid job at
uncovering their challenges and matching
up our products solution to those
challenges but on the second call they
ended up not moving forward and it was a
huge surprise to me so what is your
advice to try and minimize the surprise
no thanks so much great question
don't see my headphones in you come on
six multiplications down my headphones
first of all and I think AJ is better at
this than me I always think we're gonna
win the sale because I'm so good being a
Salesman but one of the great ways to
not be surprised on losing a sale is to
never think you've got it I think that's
actually a stunningly interesting aspect
of it I so I think not buying into your
own [ __ ] or hype is important I also
am a big fan of back-channeling I do
think that you could have been emailing
and contacting the clients some clients
are turned off by that others can really
give you some information it depends on
your relationship with that client but
but but really the truth is it's very
tough to mitigate this I mean that's the
gate right that's the that's the high of
sales you go in for the kill and you
don't know necessarily if you've made it
happen or not and so I think teetering
expectations trying to communicate fact
Channel during the time sometimes the
squeakiest wheel gets the oil sometimes
the squeakiest wheel gets taken off and
replaced by wheel it's just a way you've
got to figure out your own cadence your
own touch I'm a big fan of I always say
I like things sold before I start
selling them so if you're going in for
pitches you know a lot of times I like
having relationships putting out content
before those things I think I think
that's really an important variable in
sales which is fundamentally selling
before you're actually going in for the
sale
I do believe an answer on the askgaryvee
show will
lead to a business opportunity in the
future that's selling before selling and
so that's it I mean you can do what you
can do before the fact but once you're
in the game you can batch it a little
bit you can't either your expectations
but you've got to let the results play
out the way they will that's a good show
I think people really like when I'm in
New York City I start grabbing people to
just randomly I interacted I don't know
if you noticed a little bit more
including what I know someone even
thought was a planted person I just hope
they would that was unbelievable
statement of the day just tell me about
what you think about this show tell me
about what you think about this setting
and thinking about getting outside a
little bit more especially with the
winter you know I get a lift here up
what was that face you can talk
your softie rock you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]